morning everybody it is seven o'clock
you are very welcome to join us on the
breakfast show here on the sky news some
difficult choices facing the chancellor
this morning as public sector pay
pressures grow with more potential
strikes around the corner from other
workers new talks today to try to end
the rail strikes the rail union boss
calling for coordinated industrial
action on this program yesterday so do
public sector workers deserve a pay rise
closer to inflation the latest figures
on that uh are coming out within the
next few moments we'll bring them to you
of course plenty to ask the deputy prime
minister dominick robert very shortly
we'll also speak to a criminal barrister
who's just voted to strike about why
he's doing it and we'll ask the shadow
of culture secretary lucy powell about
those labour mps who joined picket lines
should they be sacked it's wednesday the
22nd of june
talks between the unions and rail bosses
to resume here today to try to break the
deadlock as pressure over pay grows from
across the public sector
i'm live at a food importing business in
sidcup the latest inflation figures are
expected as the cost of living crisis
continues to vote
preventing trivial human rights claims
the government plans to override
decisions made by the european court of
human rights after it blocked the
deportation of asylum seekers to rwanda
no walking stick we'll discuss these new
pictures of the queen with the royal
author robert hartman
also coming off the program for you this
morning
after a two-year hiatus glastonbury
festival is back with sir paul mccartney
among the headliners we'll be live at
worthy farm but will revelers face a
battle to get here
[Music]
we'll look ahead to that summer of
festivals as life after covid returns
with glastonbury and hyde park back this
weekend with the music journalist paul
stokes
[Music]
good morning everybody a busy show today
with rail strike talks set to resume and
a move to stop the european court of
human rights stopping asylum seekers
being deported to rwanda the deputy
prime minister dominic raab with us
shortly to discuss all of that we begin
though with breaking news on the cost of
living likely to hear that from our
business presenter helen ann smith any
moment now what are we expecting helena
yes we're expecting those figures any
moment now okay they just haven't
dropped just yet but we'll bring them to
you as soon as
they do uh it'll be the inflation
figures uh for the month the 12 months
to the month of may how much those
prices have risen we're all feeling it
in our lives aren't we that the prices
are really going up last time these
figures were released they were at nine
percent inflation and we heard from the
bank of england just a few weeks ago
that that's expected to tip up to about
11
later this year so huge huge uh
inflation numbers this month we're not
actually expecting them to hit quite
that high uh the consensus from
economist is that it'll tip up slightly
to about one point nine point one
percent excuse me uh but that's slightly
because some of the big inflationary
pushes we're expecting to see are coming
in a little later this year perhaps uh
in october so
that's up to this point inflation we
think we expect as i said we're still
waiting for those figures to drop i've
just got them here now for you so the
cpi that's the consumer price index rose
by 9.1 percent in the 12 months to may
so that was precisely what economists
were expecting tipping up a little bit
there from the 9
we had nine point one percent inflation
that's huge and everyone's feeling it in
their lives you might ask okay we're
wearing a big huge jacket and a cap here
i'm actually at a food importing
business we're in a children so this is
a a big warm coat we're quite cold in
here at the moment things will start
waking up here shortly essentially lots
of trucks coming in from europe bringing
fresh fruit and vegetables they'll get
repacked and sent around the uk the big
cost they're facing what we all are is
fuel costs their fuel costs up 30 and
that explains a little bit as to why the
food that we're buying is rising so much
in cost everyone's feeling it in their
lives and these figures really uh
demonstrating that 9.1 percent inflation
in the months to me
yeah last time you brought us those
figures you were with me up in wigan who
knows where you're going to be next
month for now thanks very much thank you
to our other main story and disruption
we'll continue across the rail network
today following yesterday's strikes with
only 60 of trains expected to run
despite talks resuming today to try to
break the deadlock most operators in
england will operate a reduced sunday
level of service and are warning
passengers of major delays in scotland
some of the main routes will operate
from quarter past seven but many others
will only resume normal operations by
early afternoon and in wales early
morning services are particularly likely
to be affected by delays and
cancellations as a rule of thumb people
are being advised only to travel if it's
absolutely essential and to check routes
and times before setting off
emma's standing by for us at
houston station here in london because
that's where the talks are going to
resume behind you later on aren't they
um emma good morning
yes hi kay so i'm at the network rail
headquarters here and it's here that we
expect the talks to resume this morning
and we understand that on the table
is a four percent
pay offer now the previous offer was
three percent that included one percent
linked to modernizations so this new
offer we understand four percent but
again
it requires these modernizations to be
accepted which network rails say will
result in 1
800 job losses however
they say the vast majority will be dealt
with through voluntary redundancy and
also natural wastage so for example
people retiring or leaving to go to
another job so that's all happening here
and behind here is houston station i
went in there this morning it was
absolutely empty at six o'clock and the
board said that the first train leaving
was to manchester piccadilly at 7 35 and
just to give you some kind of indication
uh normally
there would have been four trains to
manchester by 7 35
so quite a lot of disruption today but
apparently yesterday it wasn't too
chaotic people had stayed away they knew
that this was going to happen it will be
interesting to see how things pan out
later because of course this isn't meant
to be a strike day today
okay it isn't thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot but as you were pointing
out there's going to be all sorts of
problems on the railways check before
you travel at best a sunday service
we're being told but it'll take more
than rail strikes and travel chaos to
stop the army of festival lovers heading
to glastonbury today more than 200 000
people are heading for worthy farm worth
so paul mccartney billy eilish and
kendrick lamar will be headlining this
year after a two-year hiatus because of
covid
joining us now is katie so
it's three years then since uh they last
opened their doors i think i'm right in
saying katyanta good morning
good morning
yeah actually say 200 000 people are
going to be due on site here the size of
a small temporary village that is
erected here on worthy farm no mean feat
getting those people here and of course
many of those
who had tickets were planning on taking
the trains here over 50 special trains
are usually laid on to get people uh to
the nearest station to worthy farm
because of those two days worth of
strikes that tuesday
and the thursday both days when people
would normally travel here because the
cancellations on those days now numbers
have been cut in half there's only i
think 24 trains uh now running which has
meant this festival which sort of prides
itself on its green credentials a lot of
people of course are going to have to be
driving here now or turning uh to
coaches now glastonbury has said they're
expecting this morning up until midday
to be the busiest time of day
interestingly enough they say actually
one of the peak times when people are
arriving is actually two in the morning
overnight so why you can't actually get
access at this time of day before eight
in the morning through the through the
main gates actually a lot of people will
be already waiting in the car parts
outside a little bit of a mini festival
happening outside as they wait to get in
on the side but what you have to
remember okay this is the countryside
really small country road so it is going
to be quite a nightmare if we have a lot
more cars coming uh on site this year as
you say a two-year hiatus we've had
because of the pandemic a brilliant
lineup so paul mccartney one of the
oldest performers to headlining
headlining on saturday that's going to
be terrific of course and then on friday
night the youngest solo artist to
headline billy eilish so i think if
people can make it here if and when
they've got a good weekend of music
ahead of them big question though is
what's the weather going to do
oh well yeah don't don't ask about that
rain is expected over the weekend but
let's just focus on the sun now okay
because i remember all those pictures
came we've seen people i mean literally
up to their armpits in mud haven't we in
the past
i'm blocking that out for now okay we're
just focusing on the
the traffic hell which is going to be
bad enough and it is we don't want to be
thinking about the fact that we're going
to need wellies this weekend okay lovely
thanks very much indeed katie thank you
are you going are you planning to go why
don't you tweet us directly and let us
know what your plans are at k burley or
you can use the hashtag kaboli if you
prefer still to come on the programme
for you the deputy prime minister
dominic raab will be joining us in the
studio in a second or two then labour's
shadow culture secretary lucie power
will be with me uh just after eight
and as barristers vote to go on strike
in a row over legal aid funding i'm
going to be speaking to a criminal
barrister and that's mark mcdonald
before that though let's look at some of
today's other headlines for you and some
breaking news this morning local media
in afghanistan say that at least
255 people have been killed in an
earthquake in the east of the country
the 6.1 magnitude earthquake struck
about 27 miles from the city of coast
it's also shaking parts of neighborhood
neighboring pakistan but there are no
immediate reports of deaths or damage
there
the texas school where 19 students and
two teachers were shot dead is to be
demolished officials say police could
have stopped the government within three
minutes of him entering the building but
accused police of failing to act because
they prioritize the lives of officers
over the lives of children
three minutes after the subject entered
the west building
there were sufficient number of armed
officers wearing body armor
to isolate distract and neutralize the
subject
the only thing stopping a hallway of
dedicated officers from in room 111
and 112 was the on-scene commander
who decided to place the lives of
officers for the lives of children
riot police have used tear gas to
disperse protests in the ecuadorian
capital of quito as demonstrators became
increasingly violent
indigenous protesters have been on the
street for several days demanding lower
fuel prices and a moratorium on
extending mining and oil projects
a jury in the united states has found
that bill cosby sexually assaulted a 16
year old girl at the playboy mansion in
1975. the civil court awarded judy huss
damages of half a million dollars it
comes nearly a year after cosby's
criminal conviction for sexual assault
was thrown out and he was freed from
prison
transport secretary has temporarily
relaxed rules around airport slots to
help airlines avoid last-minute
cancellations due to staff shortages
airlines will be given a short window to
hand back takeoff and landing slots that
they can't operate for the rest of the
summer
the policy marks a u-turn for the
government after it previously demanded
airlines put on full flight schedules
start warning from the united nations
children's fund unicef about drought and
famine in the horn of africa if an
intervention doesn't happen quickly
there will inevitably be the mass death
of children in the coming months in
april the self-declared republic of
somaliland issued an emergency appeal
for assistance for
one and a half million people affected
by the drought
that number is up 85
since the start of the year more than a
hundred schools have had to shut their
doors due to lack of water
across somaliland and somalia there's
been over three thousand cases of
cholera and over six thousand cases of
measles that is again since the start of
the year
international affairs edited on waghorn
reports from rural villages in the
self-declared republic of somaliland a
warning this report contains images of
distressed children
on what looks like the surface of mars
the worst drought for 40 years is taking
hold
on land parched dry people are
struggling to survive
or fleeing
villages are emptying in this one
two-thirds of people have already left
[Music]
but some are too sick to move like
little decker
seven weeks old and severely
malnourished
her mother ian was also weak and
struggled to speak
the family is running out of food their
livestock has either died or stopped
producing milk like so many others here
under baking heat we met ismael mahmud
who's lived here 90 years and says it's
the worst drought he's ever
the deeper inland the worst the drought
we drove by one homestead after another
deserted by families as the drought
claimed their livestock
and this is the the main homestead
and
probably they had children's here they
gave birth to children's here one two
three kids here
and so you only leave if you have to
yeah yeah that is
it it's the worst
in the worst situation and they you know
that is the last thing they can do
living leaving their homes they had to
leave that no they actually had no
choice truly they had no choice
outside one village we met the governor
of the region
its people desperately need help he told
us but the drought he says is being made
worse by the war in ukraine
it may look busy but in the only big
flower mill in somaliland they are
running out of grain
russia's blockade of ukraine means they
haven't had a shipment for three months
its silos are emptying and they may soon
have to stop grinding grain
maybe everybody will lose his job also
uh
somalia population how they will get
food in general this war affected us as
a company as a company we are affected
by this war
that's it
if the mill shuts down somaliland will
lose its main source of bread
it's hard to think of a more graphic
illustration of the impact of russia's
war in ukraine on developing nations one
of the world's poorest countries
literally running out of grain its silos
standing empty while there is millions
of tons of grain stuck in ukraine unable
to get out
war and droughts now haunt somaliland
and the entire horn of africa
threatening a humanitarian disaster
unicef says without action the mass
death of children will be inevitable and
the people here know it's coming
the last of three wells in this village
to have any water left camel herders had
dire predictions
the drought is bad he says but worse is
on its way
dominic waghorn sky news somaliland
more from dominic throughout the course
of the week deputy prime minister is
here with us uh back home inflation
record highs
what are we going to do about it well
we've uh first of all we've got to make
sure we've got the strength and the
fundamentals of our economy which rishi
sunak is doing the investment is coming
in there are all sorts of things which
show that this economy the basics are
right
in relation to inflation itself
i think that's one of the reasons why
we've put such emphasis on restraint in
relation to the public sector pay and
some of the strike action we've seen
because we know that if public sector
pay keeps going up
then it will only keep inflation high
for longer we are facing a global
struggle against inflation if you look
at the uk figures they're broadly
comparable to the us or in europe the
dutch and the belgians and it's going to
be difficult and we really do understand
the pressure that those on low incomes
are facing at the moment they're
struggling to make ends meet that's why
there's a 15 billion pound package of
support
rebate 400 pounds on energy bills
cutting national insurance next month
but we do need to have the kind of pay
restraint in the public sector that
we've been talking about and which is
part at the heart of the challenge with
the unions and rmt and the strikes we're
facing otherwise we'll just have the
vicious cycle of inflation staying
higher for longer so what happened to
the pm saying last october i've got the
guts to make as a high-wage country well
that's why we've increased the national
living wage so for those eligible
workers they got a thousand pounds more
in relation to those particularly
reliant on universal credit but are in
work they'll get an extra thousand
pounds
and we want to go further and faster but
we've got an immediate global challenge
in relation to inflation very much
sparked by the combination of the
aftershocks of the pandemic as the
economies around the world have got
going again but also particularly in
relation to energy fueled by russia's
appalling invasion of ukraine and we've
got to deal with that alongside those
broader long-term initiatives a
high-wage country but um restraints on
public sector pay how does that square
because if we don't have those
restraints inflation will go higher for
longer and that will only undermine the
pay packages of workers particularly the
most vulnerable workers for a longer
period of time we are taking the action
we're taking a firm line with for
example the rmt unions precisely because
we want to protect this erosion of pay
packets by inflation and i'm afraid if
we keep seeing uh increase in those
wages it will create a vicious cycle
which will hurt them what rmt are doing
i think at one level for the unions i do
understand they feel their job is to
protect their workers
and i understand that but it is totally
counterproductive if we follow for
example network rail in the negotiations
uh with the unions uh the three percent
offer uh the unions are saying it must
be seven percent that will only
undermine the lowest paid uh workers
salaries for longer we've got to
understand that vicious cycle we've got
to avoid it uh grant chaps told me
yesterday that the government was
staying out of it
well i'm just explaining to you the
position it's absolutely right and
historically under successive
governments network rail and the other
rail employers are the ones that engage
directly um with the
unions but of course the the um there's
overall ministerial accountability for
the mandate but yes in terms of the
negotiations that's right that's the
network realtor can do so why doesn't
what you're given that why doesn't the
transport sector get in the room with
them and sort it out well do you know
what it was interesting i'm pretty sure
i heard the rmt uh leader saying that he
didn't want to
he
sit
down
didn't say it well i asked him yesterday
we we i'm afraid i think this is why uh
this risk being politicized actually the
successive approach of governments is to
have network rail uh dealing with the
technical aspects of that in the room
and i think that would hopefully
increase the chances of a if i can say a
de-politicized approach resolution which
we do want to see how long are you going
to let the strike go on for we can't
allow i'm afraid uh the unions in this
very militant way that they've proceeded
to win this argument because it will
only hurt the poorest in our society
that they're exercising their democratic
right to strike well i think uh let me
tell you why i think there's been a 16
billion pound package funded by the
taxpayer the very people who are
suffering uh as a result of the this
disruption to trains that 600 pound per
household in this country and i think
the response and that's to see the rail
industry and all those workers through
tough times during the pandemic i think
and of course after the pandemic we need
reforms because well let me explain
because of the passenger um uh
uh the people of the home the work life
balance is changing people working more
from home and also frankly there's some
practices outdated that needed to change
and to run the the railways efficiently
that's absolutely right and i think
given that big bailout that the taxpayer
put in i think a lot of people will feel
that they are irresponsible the the
unions and rmt particularly
well actually i think uh because saying
that you can't win in this negotiation
and then disrupting uh millions of
people including students who are trying
to go and sit their exams including and
and by the way kay it is always when we
have these strikes particularly when
you're talking about the trains that the
the the blue collar uh uh workers suffer
the most the people that clean uh they
know that but they've still voted to
strike well the the the rmt members have
but in broader and that's just rail
workers but i'm just saying the cleaners
the electricians those who cannot work
remotely like many white collar workers
can use in teams these are the ones that
are being disrupted the most so again i
understand why unions feel that they've
got to fight the corner of their sectors
but it is the lowest paid who suffer the
most from strike action and also if we
give in to this inflationary spiral that
the union's demands would lead to mick
lynch spoke to me yesterday and said
that he was appealing to other unions
for coordinating multi-sector strikes
for months to come it's going to be your
summer of discontent
look
we've got unemployment at
record lows lowest levels since i was
born in 1974 and the fundamentals of the
economy are strong we do understand all
of those pressures on workers
particularly for the next year with
inflation high but if we want to get
inflation down quicker we cannot relent
and i think uh on these demands happy to
take on the unions hold on
i always want to avoid conflict if i can
but i think we've got to protect the
public and the lowest paid and that
means not allowing a vicious cycle of
higher inflation for longer that is an
argument that we must stand firm on
you're responsible for criminal
barristers in your job as justice
secretary and they want 25
well i think it's um regrettable they
voted for strike action um i mean
actually it's only 43.5 of the cba
members balloted who supported these
specific additional measures just to
give you a clear understanding we've
already committed to a 15 fee uplift 135
million pounds going in the typical
criminal barrister will see an increase
of 7 000 pounds i'm introducing this
regulation it's a statutory instrument
next month i i don't think uh that uh
that it's the right thing to do and i
think if the cba leadership couldn't
convince over half of its membership to
take these specific measures i don't
think the public will be coming so
they're not going to get 25
no they'll get 15 percent as i've
already made clear okay and um let me
talk to you about um bill of rights uh
what's the need for this new bill of
rights that you've been writing about in
the papers this morning when we've
already got the european convention on
human rights and the human rights act in
effect
yeah absolutely look
we have a proud tradition of liberty in
this country we want to reinforce the
quintessentially uk freedoms
particularly freedom of speech which
we've seen whittled away in various ways
we think that that is the liberty that
guards all the others at the same time
we've seen a lot of elastic
interpretations of human rights
particularly fueled by the human rights
act sections two and three i won't go
into all the detail and we think it's
right to uh have a proper separation of
powers uh the uk court the uk supreme
court should do what it says on the tin
and be supreme in the legal
interpretations and if the goal posts
shift and you'll remember the whole
context around prisoner voting where we
were told that we had to give prisons to
the vote i think parliament should have
the last word when it comes to the law
of the land and what our reformers will
do as i said strengthen free speech but
curb the abuses for example the ability
of serious foreign criminals convicted
of custodial offences to frustrate their
deportation on frankly pretty spurious
grounds don't european court rulings
remain binding though
well so there's three contexts one in
the context of inter case law there's no
reason why as a matter of law
international domestic we need to uh
follow our courts need to follow the
strasbourg case law we'll make that
clear secondly when it comes to
individual rulings of course we're
signatories of the echr we're staying in
the east hr i think that's important the
echr will remain incorporated well
we will of course when the goal post
shift and prison of voting is the
example when what the strasbourg court
is ultimately engaged in is judicial
legislation i think for that we're right
to make clear as we did in prisoner
voting that parliament has the last word
on the law of the land i think that's a
sensible approach
and of course the strasbourg court
particularly under robert spano its
current president has talked a lot about
the marginal appreciation for domestic
institutions the rulings remain binding
well it's a matter of international law
if you get an adverse ruling against you
um of course
they're binding but what is also allowed
within the margin of appreciation where
you feel that they they're wrong is to
push back you're we're it is a totally
legitimate thing to to to press back uh
to avail ourselves the margin of
appreciation and and prisoner voting
shows that that does not lead has been
kicked out the council europe i remember
in 2015 i went to strasbourg everyone
told me we'd get kicked out of the
council of europe if we didn't give
prisoners a vote we didn't we're still
in and we've got one of the best records
of compliance let me ask you this then
you say the bill will boost freedom of
the press
does that chime with number 10
intervening to get a times article
removed about the prime minister's wife
look i don't know the specifics around
that and what i can tell you is we want
to see the judge made privacy law
curtail we think free speech in this
country is something which should have a
higher pecking order for example the
article 8 right privacy we also want to
protect journalistic sources and i think
frankly kay you know as a journalist and
a lot of people have talked about this
there's been a feeling whether it's
political correctness whether you call
it woke whatever the language is the the
scope for rambunctious but legitimate
debate has been narrowed i think our
bill of rights will strengthen the space
for those debates okay the chair of the
common standards committee chris
bryant's uh says it's manifestly corrupt
so appoint your lover
as a special adviser
what would you say to him
i don't think that's what's happened i
think that's particularly responsible
language and frankly these attacks on
carrie i think are deeply unsavory it
didn't happen because it would have been
corrupt if it had happened well look the
the the allegations that have been made
and i've read some of the newspaper
reportings has been
roundly uh uh responded to as flawed um
those are matters for number 10 for
carrie to answer but but frankly i think
what you're seeing is a political attack
on cary as a means to get the prime
minister and i think that's out of order
well lord knight says the situation is
ripe for investigation
well look um i as i say i don't know the
individual circumstances uh the prime
minister
views don't you of course i do but i'm
just saying i think that um they've been
very clear number ten has been very
clear that these uh claims are flawed so
has uh why not just have the
investigation
but actually what we've seen and we've
seen it um
on other things there's a sort of
feeding frenzy on everything or anything
that is even thrown out there as a as a
claim against the prime minister or in
this case his wife and i think that's
wrong okay but why not just have the
investigation and it's all cleared up
well
who's calling i mean lord uh lord gate
is no longer in that position there's
going to be a successful view yeah of
course i do that doesn't mean that um
there's lots of people who's use our
respect but ultimately
uh the number ten have been very clear
on this um and as i said i think it's a
partisan attack and i think it's very
it's very unfortunate it's it that
carries being used to attack the prime
minister that that's not on okay we're
almost out of time how did it fit for
you earlier on in the week for size and
being prime minister again even for a
short time do you know what i i don't um
get uh particularly overall by any of
that i'm there to do a job to support
the prime minister uh when he needs me
and uh you know we've got a great
cabinet everyone knows what they're
doing and i i'm uh really happy to hold
the reigns if necessary sounds like a
leadership pitch to me no not at all i
mean i've said before i won't stand
again
well
i i actually remember um michael goes
saying that to me
and then he stood again yeah i'm not
quite
in the same position as michael but look
i can only tell you what i've uh what i
said before okay we won't have to play
this to you in a year's time no when
you're standing no no no because the
prime minister will be poised to win the
next election
just still at the end there it's always
great to see you thanks so much for
joining us thank you quick look at the
papers for you um and let's start with
the sun labeling the rail strikes and
threaten strikes by teachers as the
start of a class war
daily mail says the labour party is in
chaos over the dispute while the eye
looks at the government's proposed laws
to limit future strikes saying they
won't fix the crisis the time says boris
johnson is prepared for the rail strike
standoff uh to last for months just
heard that from the deputy prime
minister as well and believes the
government has to win its battle with
the rail unions
and instead of pay rises or safer
working conditions the express questions
whether the strikes have actually been
brought about by the union bosses hatred
of boris johnson
tamara's here with us morning morning
thoughts morning kay well interesting on
the proposals for a british bill of
rights that dominic rob is introducing
to parliament this week something that
he has been very interested in for a
long time but lawyers are saying is it
going to work now this of course comes
hot on the heels of the rwanda flight to
take
failed asylum seekers was grounded by a
ruling from the european court last week
that of course is nothing to do with the
european union it's the court in
strasbourg the government were very
angry about it and so dominic raab is
saying today that
his proposals would stop that happening
would give parliament precedence over
its court rulings but what you're what
legal commentators are saying is that
unless we leave the european convention
on human rights devised in that we're
not going yeah indeed by british lawyers
and some tories want him to do that but
he's not going that far as long as we
remain signed up to it then we will
remain bound by the european court
rulings that will be an international
treaty and unless we propose breaking
international law then when it makes a
ruling and then the uk has got to listen
to it so there's a question about
exactly which rulings may be disrupted
by this there's also some concern about
what the justice secretary says in the
press release about it about how he
wants to stop what he calls bogus and
trivial human rights claims by people
who are citing their right to a family
life to stay in the uk and when and the
government believes they should be
deported which some civil rights groups
are saying is a power grab by ministers
when it should be judges who decide uh
whether a claim is bogus or not sort of
questions about whether this will
actually work or not and what about what
he was saying about public sector pay
indeed so after boris johnson talked
about the high-wage economy remember
when that was all the rage only eight
months ago now they're saying well we
have to show restraint the public sector
has to show restraint otherwise we will
have spiraling inflation as we did in
the 1970s and how that squares with for
example the decision confirmed by the
treasury yesterday to increase pensions
by inflation by 10
will come as cold comfort to many public
sector workers and we know a lot more of
them are planning to ballot for strike
action if they don't get a pay rise
that's above what is being proposed
which in many cases is about three
percent for teachers and nhs workers
this is what the rmt said yesterday
my advice to the unions is to campaign
on the issues and ultimately if the
government and the employers do not
change their direction i believe that
more ballots of strike action are
inevitable and more action is inevitable
and what i would say to trade union
leaders and trade union activists is we
need to coordinate and synchronize our
campaigning so that we can rebalance
the inequalities in our society
so mick lynch of the rmt there saying
i want coordinated strike action others
should take to the pickets and demand
higher pay
dominic raab said that they must not be
allowed to win the argument with what he
called their militant tactics what not
winning the argument looks like may
become clear over the next couple of
days because we understand that a four
percent pay rise is on the table with
some efficiency savings that will need
to be um worked out but four percent
rise um is that winning the argument
probably a bit more than some in the
public sector will be getting but we'll
see if any more is on offer over the
next few days if we are to avert what
the rmt has made pretty clear is going
to be many more weeks of strike action
if they don't uh get something better
than it's on offer criminal barristers
wanting uh 25 percent uh dominic rabb
saying that is not going to happen so
let's see what happens there uh as well
thanks very much tamara tomorrow's take
at nine o'clock of course meantime the
queen has been pictured um smiling and
standing without her walking stick she
has been struggling with mobility issues
over recent months but during a meeting
with the archbishop of canterbury she
was photographed without that walking
stick um so
the question is
how's she doing um and
what's going to happen next joined by
daily mail's robert hardman author of
the queen of our times
hi robert great to see you this morning
thanks for joining us um
can you tell us first of all about this
award that her majesty received
yesterday
yes it's a a a rare award for uh what
they call unstinting service to the
church and really it's hard to think of
anyone who's shown more
and stinting service to the church of
england than its supreme governor uh
she's been supreme governor longer than
anyone else in history she's been
probably the most devoted supreme
governor since henry viii invented the
role um she's uh incredibly close and
and and very involved with the uh
minutiae of church life she takes all
aspects of it very seriously her faith
is terribly important i mean all through
the jubilee we've looked at so many
aspects of her life i think what was
slightly underplayed was the role her
faith has played i mean it's not just a
question of going to to church every
sunday and and and being closely
involved with all her bishops i mean
she's done things like transform the
the maundy service we have every every
morning thursday she's she's picked that
up turned it into a a major event moved
it around the country every year you
know these these are things that um
they're little things but but over the
years um her devotion to not just the
church of england but also to other
faiths as well and she's the first uh
supreme governor of the church of
england to uh to visit a mosque it was a
hindu temple that was at a synagogue
she's met all the popes
during her reign uh and and really i
think this this award yesterday was was
just a nice recognition of the fact that
for her
um and for the church of england um you
know they they are absolutely
interlinked
great picture of the two of them there
of course they were supposed to have
been together at the service of
thanksgiving it sent paul's and the
queen couldn't make it
and of course as we know the archbishop
of canterbury sadly had uh covid and
pneumonia at the time um but how
significant is it to see her majesty
without her walking stick there do you
think
well i think it's very it's very
significant i mean these are the sort of
images um we were seeing you know during
lockdown of a monarch still very much uh
in charge going about her duties i mean
this is a sort of the nuts and bolts if
you like a monarchy it's the day-to-day
stuff that we've never normally seen the
sort of the audiences behind the scenes
and the red boxes all those sort of
things
but i think to see her clearly in good
spirits there we're seeing obviously
there's some of those great jubilee
scenes and uh
the the beacons being lit at windsor
castle um
but but you know windsor is very much
clearly home now it's the office now uh
but but the way in which i think you
know she there she was ready to meet the
archbishop um i'm clearly very pleased
to see him as you say he missed uh the
the jubilee celebrations he missed
things like this the lighting of the the
tree of trees as you may recall it was
uh that was a great evening that was on
the uh the eve of the uh the service of
some pools um that he missed um and so
uh yes i imagined for archbishop welby
it must have been very sad you had to
sit at home and watch scenes like this
uh on tv but i mean of course that that
that that is the sort of rousing finale
if you like to the entire four-day uh
jubilee celebrations and and that i
think that's gonna you know that will go
down in history as one of the
the great images there because what
you're seeing there of course are are
our four monarchs effectively there's
the queen and her three successors and
and and what a charming sight uh it was
um and i i'm certainly at the palace
there's a great sense that the jubilee
went extremely well everyone was very
happy with the sort of very touched by
the enormous public response to it
um and so yesterday was was really the
archbishop um catching up uh and and i
suspect he he wanted to give that
canterbury cross to her majesty um
during um the jubilee celebrations
obviously that was not to be his place
was taken at some polls by the
uh by the archbishop of york who made
that delightful address in which he
congratulated the queen on on the eve of
derby day saying you're still in the
saddle um uh and but uh obviously he's
he's he is the prime minister of all
england the archbishop of canterbury so
it's important that he
uh he's he's now had a sort of formal
audience um with the queen in this very
important month
um charles and camilla are doing more of
the heavy lifting of course i think
they've just about touched down in
rwanda um as we speak what they're doing
there
yeah they are there to represent the
queen at the commonwealth summit the
commonwealth usually meets every two
years all the leaders um because of
covid it's actually four years since the
last summit was held here in london in
2018 so there's a lot of a lot of
catching up to do there as well uh and
and
you talk about heavy lifting i mean
there's a classic example we've got the
prince of wales um standing in for the
queen she's still ahead of the
commonwealth very much ahead of the
commonwealth very popular head of the
commonwealth um but the commonwealth
have already agreed that in the next
reign it will be the prince of wales who
will be the next head it's not a
hereditary position but they've if you
like already appointed him uh so he's a
sort of a head designate um and he's in
rwanda uh ryan was fascinating because
it's the newest member of the
commonwealth it was never part of the
british empire uh it was it was a a
belgian colony a very unhappy belgian
colony and it couldn't wait to sign up
to to the sort of the post-imperial
british club if you like and and that's
now at the start of the queen's reign
there were only eight members and now
there are 54 and i mean extraordinarily
this week it's going to go up to 55 the
former french colony of gabon has uh
despite her speaking french and always
being within the french sphere of
influence they want to join the
commonwealth there are others in the
queue so um you know the commonwealth is
is moving forwards um and i think
the fact that it's finally getting
together after four years is that
there's a lot to do
but it's so it's a very important role
for the prince of wales because he's not
just representing his mother
and and passing on her best wishes but i
mean he's watching this organization
he's gonna lead he's watching it sort of
shape its way into the 21st century
and roles tool for william we certainly
saw that in the jubilee just turned 40 i
think yesterday
yeah he's he turns 40 this week now very
firmly established as a sort of key
player if you like in the sort of the
operational
unit of the family i mean he's
developing his own um very extensive uh
range of of interest notably i mean the
earth shot prize which is entirely his
creation i mean it's the biggest
environmental prize in the world i mean
that's that's that's a great thing in
its own right but he's still uh getting
uh very involved in standing in for the
queen that things like uh investitus for
example he's been doing a lot of those
still doing the the walk-abouts around
the country i think this week he's been
out selling um the big issue again so
you know it's it's a royal royal
business as usual
it's good to see you as always thanks
for joining us thanks okay
thank you
i'm just going to steal some of mr
raab's water actually while he didn't
have any um sorry about that
excuse me
hey fever i don't know how you're coping
with hay fever at the moment but we've
got plane trees just outside the studio
and they absolutely kill me now looking
at some pictures in the papers that have
caught our attention
uh this is the front page
excuse me of the
mail this morning showing this image of
labour mps joining the picket lines in
london supporting the rail strikes we'll
be putting that to labor just after
eight o'clock love this little picture
as well freyas pick these out for us
today contrast in the telegraph little
girl holding her bunny in an empty
station
uh in the mirror they've got this lovely
image of the summer solstice yesterday
longest day wasn't it around 6 000
druids and pagans went to stonehenge to
celebrate good for them
over to tonga for this photo where
people managed to swim
with this young whale how cool is that
uh and finally better late than never a
photo here in the mail of the 14 000
square meter moat around tower bridge in
london that's been filled with
flowers
um it's another installment of the
queen's jubilee but the flowers didn't
quite bloom in time luckily though the
installment is here to stay i remember
do you remember the installment when it
was um
uh with all the poppies and they wanted
lots of volunteers to put all those
poppies in i was very lucky to be able
to do that i'll see if i can try and
find one of the pictures for you later
on and take a look at this the biggest
fish on record found in cambodia
cambodia even it's 300
kilograms
in weight
amazing
measuring it just to be on the safe side
uh
now when faye waghorn experienced cramps
and bleeding in january of 2020 she
immediately sought medical advice at
just 31 she was diagnosed with cervical
cancer a disease that she is now
thankfully free from faye is with us now
hi faye
good morning
good morning good morning excellent to
hear that you are now cancer free
congratulations uh on that um
tell us
about what happened to you know how you
thought this isn't right i need to go
and see the doctor
yeah of course so
back in 2019
i was experiencing some lower back pain
but i suffered with hypermobility so i
kind of brushed it aside then i started
to experience irregular bleeding
so i was someone who hadn't been for my
smear test um not because i was
embarrassed or worried i'd kind of just
put it to the back of my mind that
cancer didn't run in my family and it
wouldn't happen to me
and i was wrong
yeah and so
what happened and and you're now
cancer-free how long was the process
so in january 2020 new year's day i was
rushed into hospital with quite severe
bleeding
it was around this time that the word
cancer had started to be mentioned
a week later i received my official
diagnosis and it had spread to one of my
lymph nodes
then i was told i'd be getting five
weeks of chemotherapy and external
radiotherapy
and then to finish it off it would be
internal radiotherapy and this coincided
with the start of the pandemic
yeah just looking at images of you
though how important is um the screening
process do you think
yeah so for me if i'd have been for it
it's not a case of what is for me this
is hoping that someone else will listen
and go because if i'd have gone for at
least one of my regular screenings it
would have been picked up a hell of a
lot earlier and i could have even
avoided treatment altogether
okay um
talk to us about any advice that you
could offer
other people um or indeed their families
you might be going through this process
at the moment
i think the key thing is to talk i think
there's a lot of stigma around women's
health and i think talking to your
sisters partners
girlfriends anyone you can with a cervix
really um there is no shame around it we
all need to do the same thing so just
look after yourself and
know your own normal if something isn't
right then go and see someone
okay good to talk to you i'm so pleased
that you're better
congratulations well done thank you for
taking the time to join us
thank you thank you thanks a lot dr
lloyd's with us actually um hi doc it's
good to see you this morning thanks for
joining us um what
how effective is the screening process
is it good enough
well cancer the cervix of course if
we're talking specifically about that
has been one of the big success stories
so we had a very good test in the
cervical smear
for quite a long time now so we were
able to pick up people provided they go
for screening and of course our younger
generation are being vaccinated against
the virus that causes cervical cancer so
it's a real possibility that the next
decade or so we will have no people
dying from cancer of the cervix so a
real success story but that does depend
on people being aware that that they are
needed to go every uh three to five
years for their cervical screening and
that when they get a text from their gp
they should make an appointment and get
a smear it's not the world's most
pleasant thing to have done but uh it is
fantastically effective at screening for
for this very treatable condition
um people with potential signs of cancer
can now also go in to see their
pharmacist can't they not just cervical
cancer but more generally um is that a
good idea
well i think it's a fantastic idea we in
this country
a variety of factors all seem to to make
us particularly bad at picking up cancer
early and of course the earlier you pick
up a cancer the better
it's a staggering statistic isn't it
that
previously previous to covet it was
about one patient and four was diagnosed
in a e
and i'm reading this week that it's now
one patient and three so that by the
time you've got symptoms and you feel
that you have to go to a e usually the
cancer is pretty advanced and has got
less of a chance of being cured so we've
got to turn that around so any way that
we can pick up early cancer and do
something about it is going to change
that statistic so having pharmacists who
are as you know the unsung heroes of
covid they stayed open they did the
vaccinations they got the medications
just amazing people
uh it seems
another job for them but uh i think
knowing my local pharmacist they'll be
up for it
um
it might speed up diagnosis but of
course there's a huge backlog for
treating cancer
absolutely right so the the less
the the the less skill the less
knowledgeable someone is at dealing with
cancer the more likely you are to refer
someone who may not have cancer so it
will mean that for every patient that
gets diagnosed of cancer through this
route there will be an awful lot of
patients who won't have cancer
and it's dealing with that lot as well
and dealing with the the feelings that
people have having to go through the
system and then trying to work out of
course what those symptoms mean if
they're not cancer so it's a very
complicated process and just adds as you
say to the backlog i have to refer
every patient whose cancer risk is over
three to five percent which means that
of every 100 patients that i i refer
95 of them won't have cancer so
that's an awful lot of people that have
to be seen through the system have very
expensive tests very time consuming
tests
and then come out the other end so yes
it is a big big job and just adds as you
say to the backlog but you know that's
one of the things we got to do
have you seen any cases of monkey pox
not yet no very exciting i'd really like
to there are i think only 800 in the uk
at the moment so i don't think i i
statistically i sure i hope i'll see one
soon but i haven't seen one yet very
exciting really looking forward to that
there's going to be a vaccine am i right
insane well sorry
it's going to be a vaccine
well the lucky thing of course is that
monkey pox and smallpox are very related
uh and a few years ago uh the united
states became convinced that they were
going to have germ warfare with smallpox
and so stockpiled millions of doses of
smallpox vaccine
and luckily that smallpox vaccine
actually works against monkeypops as
well so we've got a ready supply of a
vaccine already where unlike covid we
had to develop a new one so yes it's
there uh and we obviously want to try
and do do something with it as we've got
it and so identifying the high-risk
groups in the uk and getting them
vaccinated seems a sensible thing to do
something that you will have seen quite
a lot of is
people struggling with hay fever i'll
bring that up because i'm really
struggling yes at the moment what are
your top tips for hay fever sufferers
golly well uh there are effective
medicines so please do talk to your
doctor or your pharmacist there are
antihistamines there are
nasal steroids
and other other chemicals that do work
and the combination works as well and
starting early so do start taking your
preventive habit medicines before the
pollen cup stands to rise because then
you've got a body that's ready for it so
don't just wait for the first sniffle
and of course keeping the windows closed
and afraid in this hot weather and
staying away from the pollen also helps
as well
lots of people don't want to take
medication though because they think
it's going to make them um quite drowsy
um is that is that always the case
well there are antihistamines
traditionally have been a tablet that
can make you drowsy but the new
generation of um antihistamines that you
can buy over the counter uh don't make
you drowsy so no they're they're not
they're not drowsy making so don't hold
back because of that worry
um are those your crutches that i can
see in the background there how's your
foot doing embarrassing uh well i'm
coming along it's slow and steady but
i'm doing all right
okay i'm glad to see you um as usual doc
it's great to have you on the show
thanks very much indeed for joining us
thanks for having me
thank you what's it gonna be like for
hay fever sufferers today let's run out
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
apparently pollen levels are going to be
high temperatures rising in the strong
sunshine over the next few days but
there will be a cooler and more
unsettled end to the week which is not
good news if you're going to glastonbury
sorry about that
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now proof if it were needed that even
big cats have nine lives a leopard fell
down a well in odisha in india and was
stuck
and was drowning but villagers and
emergency services used a wooden plank
to help keep the leopard afloat the
rescuers then lowered a ladder into the
well
to allow him to climb up they're very
very good climbers leopards
and then he headed off not just thrown
together
um
he's off back into the wild good for him
yeah very very clever climbers uh
interestingly though did you know that
lions are not very good climbers you
think that they are they can get up a
tree they can't get down again um let's
have a look at these um latest inflation
figures for you 9.1 percent that's what
the predictions had been had been and
that's exactly what they came in at 9.1
in may it is um concerning that's up
from nine percent uh concerning that
potentially those figures could
uh go up to something like 11
by the end of the year i did put that to
the deputy prime minister dominic raab
earlier on in the programme he said it
is a problem with global inflation
but he they were obviously doing
everything they could he said to try to
bring down inflation figures but that
meant that a public sector pay needed to
remain
low he's talking about the rail union
the strikes
yesterday more strikes tomorrow of
course and then on saturday as well this
is what it looked like um yesterday and
we were hearing uh from again from the
deputy prime minister who was referring
to the unions at the rmt union as
militant uh because they had gone on
strike i'm not sure that was the correct
word to use but i pressed him a couple
of times and he felt that the union were
being
militant
the picket line is likely to be in place
again tomorrow and then again on
saturday unless the
rmt union and network rail can come to
some conclusion to end those strikes
they are meeting again probably about 10
o'clock this morning we
are hearing that potentially an offer of
4
is being noted we will
probably hear more about that uh later
on ian king live will be telling us
about that um conditional on reform of
the railway the big question though is
they're offered four percent and other
unions are offered three percent
including people like teachers etc uh
nurses doctors um is that appropriate
what will those unions
will they then do and also we've been
hearing from the barristers union they
want criminal barriers union they want
25 percent
justice secretary said not a chance
[Music]